you're a great guy and i wish you
nothing but health and happiness i want
this uh
next what is the date of the opening for
the movie uh the uh
october 22nd and in the meantime
uh you know and and also uh you are well
known not only as this crazy guy and
comedian and actor and that
you have a hot sauce oh yeah that's
right i brought you hot sauce
and then i i knew about your uh
germaphobia so i i kept it in
in the case as the hot sauce
wait what is that sticker
for your butthole wow so this is not for
food
it's for your butthole well i mean
you're gonna put it in your mouth and
your butthole is gonna love it i love
that the camera too is just facing his
butthole while he's telling
us that's okay so this is hot sauce for
your butthole and where does this where
can
listeners get this uh they can get it on
amazon prime you can get it at stevo.com
you give me a case a hot tub but i can't
give you the whole case i just wanted
you to
i'm helplessly addicted to this stuff oh
you're just showing it to us no no i
want you to take out a box
knowing that no one's touched it oh okay
i see yeah
all right and then you'll so you i love
the way you're
marketing so you only there's only nine
bottles of this which makes it
worth so much more right and i actually
just came out with
all right i'm about to launch my new
flavor
which is called stevo's butthole
destroyer
wow yeah wow it's so [ __ ] hot it's
basically useless
that's like the most that's like most
women on instagram
oh my gosh dad i'm sorry they're so
[ __ ] hot they're basically useless
am i gonna get canceled sorry you can
edit that mackenzie
but this actually this one the
original hot sauce for your butthole
it's not just
it's not about being hot for the sake of
being hot it's actually delicious and i
am
super addicted to it so so what is the
other flavor the other flavor is called
butthole destroyer
what do you how do you like when
something's so hot i don't i like hot
sauce but you don't have a taste
it's like when it heats up that much
it's just the heat but whole destroyer
has uh all three of the three
hottest peppers in the world which is
ghost pepper
scorpion pepper and carolina reaper
pepper
they're all three in there and it's just
plain [ __ ]
up man it's uh i don't expect you to
sell very very well
[Music]
that's your marketing plan
i think i think it's more of a gag thing
i don't know but but this
um you know that this original flavor
it's been uh you know have you sold a
lot
yeah it's been the number one selling
hot sauce on amazon multiple times
oh wow yeah we're uh you know
do a lot of people buy their hot sauce
from amazon um
i i don't know but we're doing
a steady without any promotion we're
doing like a steady
30 grand a month wow wow wow
yeah just on on amazon we're in the
wrong business
we should be in the hot sauce
you know i think you're aware of that
but uh you gotta have and you're using
your butthole as your rev
rubbish yeah i've got the hot sauce and
i've got the video on what else you're
selling anything you want to push
my uh my my new comedy special i put it
out on my own
on uh on my website stevo.com
okay so they can download stevo.com it's
super nice and is this the one where we
can hear about the
the see the things that you were talking
about here like the the
vasectomy and the it's not the the
bucket list is
the one with the vasectomy and the
ejaculating as i fell out of the
airplane yeah uh that one's still
a touring act but but my previous comedy
special which is called gnarly
that's the one where i uh suffered the
burns
and had skin grafts on 15 of my body
and uh it's arguably the first
like genuinely multimedia comedy special
where the stories that i'm telling in my
stand up are
illustrated by interstitial footage and
like
most comedians i think aren't like very
uh
sticklers for telling the exact truth
right
not only am i a stickler for telling the
truth in my stand up but i actually back
it up with the footage show and tell
so it's just it's just it's it's a
really original uh
take off i can't wait to see it i'm
gonna see it i'm gonna go download it so
that's at stevo.com
it is yeah and then the hot sauce is at
amazon and stevia.com and stevo.com yeah
we've got
all kinds of um merchandise drugs
merchandise uh
a lot of autographs yours the white
t-shirt is this something you're telling
me
okay i i actually was it was sensitive
to i thought i wanted to
to look clean like i didn't want to
freak you out like if it was
dirty or germs so i thought a nice clean
nice shirt and then talk about the
your [ __ ] in your fiance's uh vagina
that's it yeah well that's and and the
movie comes out october
22nd i've got my own podcast stevo's
wild ride
available wherever podcasts are podcasts
yeah and when does that that drops uh on
thursdays thursdays yeah this week is
actually with my dad
my name is stevo's dad on the podcast
wow we just had post malone
we we recently had mark cuban wow uh
mike tyson shaquille o'neal wow
like i've had i've had a lot of uh good
fortune with my guests
because everybody's got a podcast you
guys really do well look at what we have
we have stevo and i've got
seth right i got kyle awkwardly sitting
and my daughter
and my daughter beside me so we have a
full array too
yeah i mean absolutely absolutely and i
mean dude
your career speaks for itself it's
really an honor i don't even need to
speak
i'd like to sit quietly and people could
just listen to me sitting
it's on my podcast it's truly an honor
howie
my honor i'm a fan that's why i
remembered your act i love that you are
a hard worker i'm a big fan of the
jackass movies i'm a big fan
of steve oh thank you and uh getting to
know you a little bit more was real
eye-opening and a pleasure you yeah and
i i appreciate that i
i i would imagine your parents are proud
of you that's why your dad is showing up
on the thing
yeah yeah dad dad's epic
you